right so uh thanks a lot for inviting me
I'll talk about first order model
counting and how you can use it to
compute probabilities in an interesting
way so first I want to give a very
high-level motivation very similar to
what other people talked about today but
what is this stuff good for so here's
one motivation what I would like to do
is I would like to ask Google does there
exist a co-author of Einstein and eros
and currently the systems that we have
don't really allow us to answer these
questions but if you look at the small
print you see for instance that Einstein
has an earnest number of two which means
that yes there should be some one in
between so this is a motivation to have
query answering and actually all the
ingredients are already there so Google
knows about Albert Einstein it has in
its knowledge graph all of this
information it also knows about eros and
it also knows about this guy Adam
Strauss who happens to be a co-author of
both Einstein that's nice
so clearly all of the entities are in
there we just have to join them and find
the right answer it so what I would like
10 years from now is that I get this
answer yes Ernst rouse is probably the
guy you're looking for Barack Obama also
published the paper Justin Bieber
probably not right so why why is this
uncertain well all of these facts come
from information extraction systems that
our statistical systems so really we
need probability here and also a for the
machine learners this cannot come from
label data you will never have websites
that list specifically who are you know
co-authors with one author in between I
mean some of these things you really
need query evaluation so ok I'm
preaching to the choir here but this is
my motivation for Pro boosting query
evaluation so that's one motivation and
the reason by the way that it's not
solved yet is because the likes of
Google and Apple and Amazon they're
solving a much more simple problem which
is answer queries that's you know
explicitly appear on some website for
instance in January if you would ask
who's playing in a Super Bowl
next week you would get
last year's teams so this is an article
in the New York Times that tells you you
know actually these systems they're
really not there yet so they definitely
don't care about doing joints on their
produced ik databases yet so that's one
motivation here's a completely different
motivation very similar to what Lisa
Couture talked about this statistical
relation we want to have things like
Bayesian networks but we want to extend
it with relationships for instance
saying that friends have similar smoking
habits and that asthma can be hereditary
and then there's a whole bunch of
different representations out there
including a PS cell including block they
all have their advantages but it looks
roughly like this you have a relational
model with probabilities or weights so
that's my second motivation and I'll get
back to these both of these motivations
later on after I explain the more
technical stuff so why do we need
first-order probabilistic reasoning why
do we need to have a special algorithm
to do pro Mystik reasoning for these
relational representations and here it's
a very simple example that shows you why
why we need this and it's actually a
system so someone tried to use one of my
pro music inference systems to solve
this problem here you have a deck of
cards that's shuffled and you would like
to ask what's the probability that the
first card is hearts really easy one
over for all right what's the
probability that the last card is spades
given that the first card is the Queen
of Hearts a little bit more difficult
conditional probability 13 over 51 so
these are really simple questions that
you would like to maybe ask when you're
doing some kind of game engine
development so let's try to automate
this let's try to build a formalistic
graphical mole to answer these types of
queries so here you have a random
variable for every card in your deck and
the values tell you which guard is
behind this position right and now let's
take our favorite pro holistic inference
algorithm to answer these queries right
and some of you may know what's going to
happen next so what you get is a fully
connected graphical model because all of
these random variables they say that for
instance this card and this card they
cannot have the same value and for every
pair you have this type of constraint
between your and over
and if you run your textbook AI Prabhu
stick reasoning algorithm on this no
matter what you choose you get something
that will build you a table of 52 to the
52 rows so even though this is a super
easy problem actually we don't really
have general purpose tools that that can
solve these types of things I would
argue okay and it's not just in this and
a contrived example that you see this
behavior if you take your statistical
relational model for instance a very
simple one that says faculty webpages
are more likely to link to course
webpages and if you even if you have
just 26 web pages you already have this
graphical model here and as you can see
it's also very densely connected and
very symmetric all right
if you only have a thousand pages or you
have a million random variables and
factors and you couldn't even draw this
on a slide so traditionally we would say
using algorithms like variable
elimination this would be highly highly
intractable but we'll try to deal with
that with the algorithms that we
developed okay so what's going on here
why is this an easy problem for us and
not for these general purpose algorithms
well the reason is that if I ask this
query for the first cart being the Queen
of Hearts or the what does it you add
the Queen of Hearts or for the second or
the third one I always get the same
probability right so what you really
have here is some additional property
which you could call some high-level
reasoning you don't reason about every
card individually you reason about them
as a whole group there's a relational
structure because you can say that
they're entities and relationships
between them and this is how you see the
world when you solve this problem you
could say there's symmetric the cards or
you could say in statistics that are
exchangeable right and and lifted
inference what we try to do is build
inference algorithms that take into
account these properties to speed speed
things up
so how does it work how do these
algorithms actually exploit these
symmetries so to explain this I will
also use this very basic problem of
model counting which I think some people
already mentioned so in model counting
you're trying to count solutions to a
sentence in propositional logic in first
order model counting you assume that
there is some finite domain and the
sentence in first order logic and you
try to count how many solutions are
there to my sentence in first order
logic and if you for instance have this
sentence saying on every day if it's
rainy then it's cloudy and there's only
one day then these are all of your
possible joint assignments to your
variables and three of them are models
right it's pretty easy but now I can
also increase the domain I can see there
are two days then I have this many joint
assignments and now there are nine
models and what we'll end up using to as
a basic engine for probablistic
reasoning in this context is something
called weighted first order model
counting where the weights are now the
difference and here we say that there is
a weight for every assignment you could
make if you say that it's rainy on the
Monday its weight one if it's not rainy
on a Monday that gets way to and for
every possible assignment you make
there's some weight or some cost
associated and now for every model you
can also just multiply these costs sum
them up and you get your weight at first
order mobile count so weighted model
counting which is the same thing for
propositional logic is kind of like a
basic engine for protic reasoning in
bayesian networks in many propositional
representations and now it will turn out
that we can also solve a lot of
relational probabilistic reasoning
problems using this task of weighted
first order model County
so how how do we build engines that do
this well it's actually really easy it's
almost the same algorithm that then
switch to introduced this morning this
is what he introduced you have some
rules the probability of the negation of
a query is 1 minus the probability of
your query if you have independent
queries you can multiply their
probabilities and so on and so on
alright so remember this from this
morning well if you want to do weighted
first order model counting the rules
look almost exactly the same only there
are certain things called these
normalization constants so think of just
model counting assume that every model
has weight one then this tells you that
the number of models of the negation of
a sentence is just the number of total
interpretations minus the number of
models of the negation of the degree so
all of these rules they have their
weighted analog and don't worry too much
about the details here but it's
essentially the same algorithm that then
introduced this morning right and indeed
if you have a general weighted first
order model accounting program this is
kind of the best you can do and
everything dan talked about the
dichotomy all those things kind of carry
over to this problem of first order
model counting but actually in AI we're
interested in a slightly different
version of the first order model
counting problem and it's the one that
you get when you take things like Markov
logic networks and you convert them to
this specific problem so here's an
example of a simple market logic network
smokers are more likely to be friends
with other smokers and the way that we
reduce this to a model counting problem
is by constructing a formula that will
counter model stuff and also a weight
function that assigns the weights to
every possible assignment you make right
so this is the formula it's the same
formula we have in the ML n but now we
make this formula equivalent to a new
relational symbol and the only thing
that this does is it carries the truth
value of your formula in every possible
world so where previously you would say
you know depending on whether this
sentence is true for every x and y you
get this weight
you say you know depending on whether
this sentence is true for every X and y
f of X Y would be true or false it's
really catch it's really capturing that
sentence all right people don't look
confused usually okay and now it's
really easy now we just have to define
our weight function and our weight
function says every time that f is true
we'll multiply by this number here e to
the 3.75 if F is false then we
multiplied by one and if you know a
little bit the semantics of emmalin's
that's exactly what what is the the
definition of this weight here it says
that every world
for every pair of people for which is
sentence is true you multiply by e to
the 3.75 to get the weight of your world
and a later you have to normalize and
indeed this normalization this partition
function of my Markov logic Network
which is the partition function of the
mark of network I get when I ground it
to a proposition propositional Markov
network this is the same as the weight
at first order model count of this
sentence with respect to this weight
function here all right so that's why we
say that all of these complex
correlations that you get in statistical
relational learning you can just turn
them into a query on a probabilistic
database or equivalently equivalently a
first order model counting problem on a
sentence and the weight function that's
how all of these things are connected
now with this extra assumption that we
have this type of reduction going on
there's one key observation which is
that all of these weights of all of
these tuples they're all exactly the
same right for every pair of people and
the sentence is true you always multiply
by the same number here so this tables
are completely symmetric and instead of
assigning a weight to a tuple what
you're what you're actually doing here
is assigning a weight to a relational
symbol and this allows us to actually
come up with additional inference rules
beyond beyond the ones that Dan uses
that allow us to speed things up so
these are the rules here's just an
example previously if we had
this variable for all Z the sentences to
be true we will multiply if they're
independent multiply these probabilities
for all of these instantiation of the
sentence instead of multiplying things n
times now we can just take it to the
power of n but this is a bit abstract
let me just give you an example of a
very specific way that we use this
property of symmetry between the weights
to compute probabilities or model
accounts so let's assume that all of the
weights are 1 they're all symmetric and
they're all one so what we're now doing
is just counting how many solutions are
there and the weights there kind of you
know redundant now so how many solutions
are there to this sentence in first
order logic for all people x and y if X
smokes and X is friends is right and Y
has to smoke I don't know if this is
immediately obvious how many solutions
there
so I'll tell you but first observe that
this is actually a hard query all right
this is it's not we cannot compute this
with if we don't so on a promising
database this would be hard to compute
so how do we compute it if we just
assume that all of the weights are one
all of the weights are symmetric well if
I tell you precisely who smokes I'll
give you a database of all of the
smokers and I'll tell you that that K of
them smoke then it's pretty easy then
you can just count how many combinations
are possible for the friendship relation
so if there are K smokers they can be
friends with all of the other case
smokers this is allowed the non-smokers
are also allowed to be friends with the
non-smokers the only thing that's not
allowed is for the smokers to be friends
with the non-smokers and then this
relation is also allowed so this tells
us that the number of solutions that are
available after I know all of this
information is due to the number of
friendship relations except for the ones
that have to be false I didn't tell you
you know in the beginning precisely who
smokes and at Eric a smoker so let's
let's bring it closer to the original
problem but say that we know that there
are K smokers so now I don't give you a
database but you know that the number of
different databases in which K people
smoke is n choose K right and then
finally you also know that K the number
of smokers could be anything from zero
to n so in total my model count is this
number here this is one example of a
lifted inference rule that can solve
these types of problems and that goes
beyond what is possible in provost ik
databases why because of the symmetries
in the problem does it make sense
so what should we do if we get some such
a problem like this deck of cards here
we should just encode it in first order
logic we should say for all positions in
the deck there exists one cards for all
cards there exists one position and in
the same position there cannot be two
different cards and this completely
specifies a deck of cards in first order
logic and then if you run these
algorithms
so the algorithm that then suits you
developed plus these special rules to
deal with the symmetric ways then you
would count the models as being this
expression here and you see that it has
these exponentiations these binomial
coefficients that we had in the example
before and if you simplify this what you
get is n factorial which you know is the
number of models of this sentence
because it's a number of ways to shuffle
a deck of cards right and what's
interesting here is that we can compute
this in time polynomial in and well
previously we had this huge densely
connected graphical model with 52 to the
52 rows in our tables now we can just
compute this with you know two nested
for-loops
right so this is where the power of
lifted inference comes in for the
symmetric case in addition to everything
you saw this morning okay so this is how
the algorithms work roughly so this sent
this this expression is generated by the
inference algorithms this expression but
to evaluate it mm-hm
are you happy with this expression is
the number of are you trying to get an
evaluation we try to evaluate it yeah
the exponentiation here takes
logarithmic time right and then you have
two nested for-loops so another
quadratic term but yeah we can we can
look at that in detail afterwards
okay I did a complexity again fine yeah
yeah so it's data complete I will talk
about long day that complexity later
yeah okay
so this is how the algorithm works so
when does it work you know when do we
get a benefit out of this way of doing
things so first I mean maybe some of you
are wondering why not just use a
propositional model counter why not use
some of the tools developed for instance
by Bart's you know what's what's the
difference here so I'll ask you what
happens if you generate a grounding and
instantiate or the lineage of your your
sentence here you generate this huge CNF
and you would give it to a model counter
you think it will work I mean you
already saw that it's a very densely
connected Hydrabad graph but okay maybe
it's still tractable for these counters
it's possible well it turns out that no
and I'll give you a very quick intuition
why so this is the same problem shown as
a as a bipartite graph we have all of
our cards and all of our positions and
these are all of the random variables
expressed by edges so this random
variable here says that cards
King of Hearts is assigned to the last
position in the deck all right so a
model here so one model of this sentence
in first order logic is simply a perfect
matching in this bipartite graph all
right it's matching every car to every
position final observation is that if
ice so if I count models I'm counting
perfect matchings okay and then the last
interesting observation is that if I set
the weights of my propositional
variables of my assignments to be
arbitrary then I'm allowed to set them
to zero I can say that it's impossible
for the King of Hearts to be in position
52 right and I can encode this any way I
want so then here's the bottom line by
setting my weights I can encode an
arbitrary bipartite graph by just
removing edges here by setting their way
to zero counting models is counting
perfect matchings and this is sharpy
complete for bipartite graphs so what
this means is at any rate at model
counting solver any model counter that
can handle our
carry weights or unit clauses will
always require exponential time here
assuming you know what you're really
comparing two different type of
complexity because you're comparing
combined complexity with data complexity
now you could make statement about them
but don't say that one is easy one is
hard when you are comparing two
different things if you want to do that
do that do this comparison of combined
complexity on both sides and then we'll
receive meaningful comparisons so this
is for a fixed query for just this deck
of cards and for once you once you
boolean eyes it we can we cannot take
advantage of the things we don't know
this no because I'm still comparing both
algorithms on only one query and just
growing the right so as a function of as
a function of the number of cards in
your deck
this here will require exponential time
while the the nested for loop I showed
you with people in nominal time so it's
really data complexity in both cases all
right so here are some more results
though this is what we know about this
first order model counting problem so
this is everything that Dan told you
this morning there exists this class of
safe query safe ucq queries and they
have also their analog as safe CNF
queries and for these queries dance
algorithm can solve all of them
efficiently all right at least for the
this the ucq ones and and this is what
don ôt on i told you about this morning
it says that so he has a different name
for this a slightly different
characterization but you can extend this
with negation and still the pro stick
database algorithms can solve many of
these problems but there's more so one
of the key results specifically for this
first order model accounting problem is
that every sentence in fo to every CNF
in fo two can also be counted
efficiently so fo 2 means that you have
a CNF with which clauses and every class
has at most two logical variables two
quantifiers
and actually it doesn't really matter
what the quantifiers are any sentence in
effort to can also be the Mobile's can
also be counted in polynomial time yeah
so this is over symmetric structure
symmetric weights and we also show that
gamma a cyclic conjunctive queries can
also be done efficiently so these are
all the new results you get when you
have this very symmetric setting so here
are some interesting observations this
is the hard query that both the the both
of the dance talked about so this is
actually sharply hard to compute on a
pro holistic database but counting its
models it's also polynomial time in the
size of the domain you may wonder what
if I have a sentence with three logical
variables what if I have a CNF with you
know three logical verbals in the
clauses well the cards example is one of
them so some of them clearly are also
efficient to compute a model count of
this one here that's four okay so that
one is not in there this one is also
efficient by the way right there are
also hard ones so we know that not all
of the CNS with three logical variables
are efficient to compute a model count
of Y because you can actually construct
a sentence that counts accepting
computations of a Turing machine so you
can construct a sentence that's what's
called char p1 complete so it's it's
solving all problems in sharpy with the
unary input and we showed it this
sentence you can actually write it with
only three logical variables so there
exists this sentence here that probably
we can never do this lifted inference
for efficiently there also exists a
conjunctive query that is a Sharpie one
heart right so I won't go into the
complexity details here but we can talk
about it afterwards
cns they're not a super set of safe
monotone sinners because it's only for
big ones for me this is correct you say
the safe type one CNF Spanish or today
it looks like the superset of the same
monotone CNF but it's only for the
driver placement so these are ones that
have negation these don't have negation
so it's definitely a superset oh yeah so
they might overlay yeah so depending on
how you define it you can yeah so this
one oh yeah this one means just add
negation and something stay stay
efficient let's let's keep it at that
level okay so a bunch of things are hard
but then a lot of very simple queries we
just have no clue so here's a very
simple one with three logical variables
it says that the friends relation is a
transitive relation super easy sentence
super easy to ask mathematically how
many how many transitive relations are
there over a social network of n people
a graph and people and no one knows how
to count as efficiently as far as I know
so if you go and look up in the
combinatorial enumeration literature
people have this recursion formulas but
no one really knows how to do it
efficiently in time polynomial in the
size of the graph right so this is a
very simple problem that we really don't
know that the complexity of for model
counting
when was it like sixties Lipsky a ton of
zero one low and it started I started by
counting models that's exactly the doing
for the symmetric case yeah so we have
we have an anecdote about this towards
the ends yeah if I get there so for the
machine learning learners I have a
cartoon version of this result which
says that a photo is liftable it doesn't
matter what you want to express you know
colleagues of the same age or more
likely to be friends any kind of
correlation you want to express between
pairs of entities and it doesn't matter
how many you you've got you can always
compute a partition function of your
Markov random field in time polynomial
in the number of people so that's the
the machine learning version of this of
this result all right so what is this
really good for I gave you this
motivation in the beginning and and you
know how does it match how do we use
this for that so remember we'd like to
ask does there exist this go after and
this is what you'd like to get but I
would like to argue that the way that we
currently do clear evaluation in
probabilistic databases does not exactly
fit reality in many ways but you know at
least in this way in that these tuples
we don't have all of them available for
instance it's very possible that Nellore
deep dive of your or your favorite
Prosek database system that it's missing
this one fact that arrows and Strauss or
co-authors with some probability right
and this means according to the closed
world assumption that this query here
has zero probability because Einstein
has co-authors but none of the none of
those people are co-authors of Erdos so
this thing has zero probability all
right this thing also has zero
probability that Bieber and eros share a
co-author that Einstein and eros shared
a specific co-author Strauss zero
probability that Bieber and that Bieber
is that person and also that Einstein
and Bieber wrote the paper and
simultaneously did not write a paper
together so all of these queries all
have probability zero and intuitively of
course this doesn't really make sense to
assign zero to all of these
probabilities to all of these queries
intuitively we know for instance that
this
we should have a higher probability than
these guys because this this is a more
general question right this this ones
entail this one right we also know that
they should have a higher probability
than this query because actually this
should always have zero probability no
matter what your prabhu stick databases
because it's unsatisfiable and then
there's also some more vague sense of
relative probability which says that you
know these two queries logically
speaking they're incomparable but we
have all of this evidence that Einstein
wrote papers with all of these people
and we have no evidence that Bieber
wrote any papers so intuitively this
probability should also be higher than
this one even though both of them cannot
be proofed in any way with the tuples
that we have available all right so
that's a problem so here's another
problem with the current way that people
use producing databases for for these
knowledge graphs if you're a machine
learner you're familiar with this
Bayesian learning loop you have some
prior belief about these guys being
co-authors you observe a webpage to read
some text on your machine learning
algorithm conditions your distribution
on this information and then changes
your belief you observe another page
your belief changes it's a very nice
principled and sound way of reasoning in
machine learning all right well this is
not exactly what's going on in knowledge
knowledge graphs so in knowledge graphs
what goes on is that first your database
is empty this tuple is not in your
database it has probability 0 then
you'll read a webpage you find some text
here and you know this evidence makes
you change your belief to be 20%
probability and so on and it looks
innocuous but what's really going on
here is that this is this is absolute
mathematical nonsense as far as I
understand that you can never have a
belief that something is probability 0
condition your distribution on an event
and then get a nonzero probability out
of it right so mathematically this whole
learning loop that people use in
knowledge base completion at least when
it's based on the closed world
assumption is completely broken from a
principled mathematical point of view so
also this is something I don't really
like even though it works in practice of
course here's another problem we
it is worse if you look at this
knowledge basis and look at the
probabilities of the tuples in there
they're almost all very close to a
hundred percent why because these things
read the web constantly and they're
extracting all of these tuples and most
of them are very unlikely and they're
just go to the garbage right so only the
most likely tuples are kept which means
that we know that there's a whole bunch
of tuples here that we don't you know
that we intentionally threw out and you
may wonder yeah okay this is a temporary
issue you know at some point we will
have found all of the tuples and I want
to also show you that this is not the
case if you just have a binary relation
at the size of Facebook so a couple
billion people then to have a
probability a real Bayesian belief about
every pair of people being siblings you
need already 200 exabytes of data and
how much is this well all of googles
storage is only a couple exabytes which
is this many punch cards above the city
of Boston so 200 exabytes for one table
is really really a lot of data and I
don't think we can ever assume that we
will complete this knowledge basis and
and that's a closed world assumption
will at and at any point in time start
to hold ok so here's a very simple
solution it's definitely not a perfect
one but it's let's say going in the
right direction so we already saw that
these knowledge bases they throw out all
the tuples that are less than let's say
you know 70% probability
okay so let's assume that everything
that's that's not in our database has a
probability between 0 and 70% we just
don't know what it is all right so this
is a you know very close match to how
these systems are used in practice and
what we can what we then can do is is
ask what is the probability of my query
for any kind of choice of probability
for the tuples that are missing and now
we cannot compute one probability
anymore but we can compute lower and
upper bound so for instance here this
probability of the query two we know
that it's larger than or equal to zero
because if we don't add any tuple store
database if they all happen to have
probability 0 that's the probability
we're getting for this query here now I
also can say that
you know it's possible to add this one
tuple to our database with probability
lambda which is our threshold and if I
if I do so then my probability becomes
0.7 times lambda and this is the maximum
probability I can ever get from my query
by completing the database so in this
open world promising database work what
we propose is these semantics a very
simple extension of the existing ones
and I think it makes it makes sense how
do we compute these things well the
lower bound probability for UC Q's is
just the probability of the query on the
database without adding tuples this is
our closed row probability and Dan knows
how to compute this very efficiently
right the upper bound is also easy to
compute in the sense that we can add all
of our tuples lambda to the database and
then compute the probability of our
query and this gives us an upper bound
because of ucq being a monotone sentence
so yes this is polynomial time if from a
complexity point of view but you get
your quadratic blow-up and you you're
basically built this 200 exabyte dataset
right so this is not really a practical
solution even though complexity wise it
looks fine
so let me give you a rough intuition of
how you can do better let's look at a
specific query and how the pro ballistic
database system would compute it so here
it would look at every individual person
X and solve the problem independently
for all of these X's and then combine
them in this way right this is the
inference rule that then showed you this
morning and it completes this polynomial
time if you do this you have to do this
recursively so you end up looping over
all the people in your domain
recursively now a key observation is
that a lot of these sub queries here
they have no supporting facts in the
database because for instance D is not a
scientist and has no co-authors or yeah
so a lot of these things actually have
no support in the database which means
that they have probability 0 in the
closed world which means that you can
just ignore all of these and there is a
way to implement the Provos
database algorithm to actually have
complexity that is linear in the size of
your database instead of being
polynomial by being clever about you
know not looking at parts of your
database that are useless to you so
that's nice
actually the dichotomy of Dan is not
between sharpie and P time but it's
between sharpie and linear time this
goes wrong if you have an open world
setting because now these things even
though they have no support in the
database they still have some
probability so the nice thing is that
and then you get into your 200 exabyte
problem now the nice thing is that all
of these queries that have no support in
the database they all have the same
probability so you can compute all of
them
together with this one expression so
here's where I tied the motivation I
have for open world perma stick database
query evaluation to this first order
model counting problem computing the
probability of all of these guys over an
empty database that's exactly the way
that first order model counting problem
so all the algorithms that I talked
earlier about allow you to do this
efficiently without getting this extra
cost and it also means that if you do
this well you again get linear time
complexity so here's the overview dense
to choose dichotomy is between
polynomial time and let's call it P P
now instead of sharpy if you implement
it nicely you can make it a dichotomy
between P P and linear time and
surprisingly for open world promising
databases where you have a polynomial a
larger number of variables you can still
compute all of these linear time queries
in linear time in the size of your
closed world database so you don't run
into this 200 exabyte problem you just
again do just one pass of your data and
of course the P P queries they stay P P
hearts we also look at queries with
negation where linear time queries can
either stay linear or become as hard as
np-complete and some of the PP queries
on the open worlds they stay P P heart
and others become n P to the P P
complete so there is a lot of complexity
stuff that you can study in this context
here's an other so okay so this
and wraps up the the query evaluation
motivation for first order model
counting its open world query evaluation
here's the other motivation which comes
from the statistical relational learning
community which is that if I want to for
instance learn the parameters of my mark
of logic networks I have to learn these
weights here to learn these weights I
have to compute the partial derivatives
of the likelihoods with respect to these
weights which ends up being a count in
your database very efficient you just
count how often is this sentence true in
my database and then here you count the
expected number of times you expect this
sentence to be true in a random database
and this here this requires inference
this requires that you compute your
partition function of your Markov logic
network and also no surprise this
problem is also simply first order model
counting and if you now plot first order
model counting into your parameter
learning algorithm what you get is for
instance this behavior where we change
the domain size of the number of people
in our ml n and with 30,000 people we
learn the parameters over ml n in 12
seconds and it doesn't make me look
expressive 30,000 people but if you look
at the mark of network that's actually
learned here it has 900 thousand 900
million random variables so these are
really really very large very densely
connected graphical models and computing
their partition functions is really
efficient the amount of money they lost
in 1995 yeah I made up that now it's
this squared plus the same number yeah I
didn't make it up if you would run
variable automation it would look like
this it would just go up here for like
10 people it would start to break right
all right now you can do the same thing
with structure learning you can use
structure learning of these liftable
models and you get much much better
likelihoods for your statistical
relational learning algorithms so let's
leave it at that I think I have like one
minute left one minute for the broad
picture for you know all of the other
questions that may arise this is a very
general framework we have logic with
weights you can apply this to other
types of logics obviously
you can use the semantics of logic with
weight functions to do probabilistic
reasoning it's it's kind of like an
automatic way to to do Pro ballistic
reasoning in different contexts for
instance some work that we try to do is
on using SMT so another first-order
theory with linear inequalities and
compute the volume of your SMT theory
with respect to a weight function where
we try to use the algorithms by moshae
and by Bart's and and other people based
on Universal hashing I wouldn't say that
we solved this problem but at least it's
the direction that I think is
interesting and promising another
direction is probabilistic programming
what if your logic what if your logic is
a logic program or a data log program
now you can ask what are the models of
my data log program with a bunch of
weights for all of my tuples in the
database and compute for instance
probabilities here for the network
reliability problem or any kind of data
loss where you have so for the
functional programming people this looks
like logic but it's really a pro stick
program that tries to find a path in a
graph so if you're more into functional
Pro mistic programming all of these
logic based techniques they also apply
to your discrete functional robusta
gramming language is in a very nice way
knowledge compilation then talked about
it there is also a first-order circuit
language that expresses these
computations so it's kind of a
declarative way of specifying the model
counting and it can be done also in
polynomial time if you're into MCMC
these IDs you can also just take them to
your favorite MCMC algorithm and exploit
the symmetries by mapping in your Markov
chain mapping a given state to one of
the approximately symmetric states and
and and kind of exploit the same
exchange ability and symmetry that you
exploit when you do this model counting
inside of an MCMC algorithm yesterday
there was a very interesting talk on
exchangeability that I watched on
YouTube because I wasn't here so there I
think exchangeability is used to
characterize what's computable and in
this work exchangeability is used to
characterize what is efficiently
computable in polynomial time so there's
some connection there that I don't
understand but I think it's interesting
so for instance all of the the whole
tractability of
two can be characterized as a specific
form as a form of partial
exchangeability with a specific type of
statistic so there's a connection there
that I don't have time to talk about
zero one loss I had a slide about it so
all of these theoretical results are
tied to the spectrum problem you can
also study the combined complexity of
first order model counting which happens
to be MP complete for fo2 and
pspace-complete for fo in general zero
one loss are obviously related as the
limit of your first order Mulligan's so
all these things I don't have time to
talk about so this is the conclusion I
think relational probabilistic reasoning
is very interesting because it combines
all of us here and you cannot argue with
the need for relational models
probability statistical machine learning
and also scalability for specifically
the open world data model I think it
makes sense because it matches what
people use in practice how they use
their knowledge graphs you get free open
world square evaluation for you see
queues but if you have negation in your
query it gets very expensive and then
finally this is kind of the history of
holistic reasoning in AI at least you
know conditional independence speeds up
your inference exponentially contextual
independence local structure set solving
techniques speed up your per basic
reasoning exponentially and then I hope
by the end of the decade we'll all agree
that symmetry exchange ability that does
the same for you and I think multiple
people are you know looking at that
direction as a property so thank you
so I think if you look at faking theorem
I don't think you'll find a good
connection there because they can use
beautifully elegant model thirteen
techniques but it goes away completely
from the counting aspect of figure so so
figure actually emailed us the Locarno
women of support for Russian and they
they actually go by very very very
painstaking counting argument expression
that they get and they take them and see
what happening totally and ensure that
this expression go to zero one it's a
very very different we spend a month
reading the paper I thought it was only
in Russian bombs and that's why what
they got out of this is that the
probabilities converts asymptotically
exponentially fast but they combined it
can define elimination with counting
like feather yeah but but it was still
the bound of the extension axiom
yourself it was that exact counting it
so we can try to do the extension action
but not for a specific specific it's the
paper I would look so when we did this
work on sharpie one actually fig and
emailed us saying oh it's really great
because when I try to prove the zero one
law instead of doing the the way the
proof that I used I actually tried to
show that the limit of the model
accounts of my sentence with approach
zero or one and I worked on it for six
months and I can consult it and he says
and now you prove that actually what I
was trying to do is sharpie one complete
so you prove that my you know in the
initial approach could never have worked
so so here he emailed us about this
right then couple questions one is in
the open database your solution we had
lambda everywhere said this
probabilistic database or I understand
this is
right it could be so in the open world
promising database setting I just assume
there is a prolific database that comes
from Nellore deep dive or Google
knowledge fault or novel knowledge graph
that that is just tuples extracted with
statistical machine learning from text
right so that's the motivation there the
mln reduction is the the motivation for
the other side of things for the
statistical relational ring site where
so these are actually different things
and I made one more comment which is a
so I'm the mathematical nonsense moving
from zero probability to conditioning
that is it is not said weaken my
statement there
so I think if one of I don't know if it
was your papers or me puts paper they'll
be one of the ones you first wrote
together you give an example that you
get a lot of speed up but as soon as you
have evidence on three of the smokers
then it's slower than just grounding the
whole thing in the real world yes yes so
for this partition function computation
and learning tonight the reason why it
works is because you don't have evidence
and you have all the symmetries of
course if you want to do prediction then
you condition on a social network on a
bunch of data and all of the symmetries
in your graphical model or gone and in
the original work on exploiting
symmetries in MCMC this would only work
if if you had exact symmetries in and
this paper that I did together with
Matias nippers we said even though there
is this evidence and everything is
asymmetric you can actually very easily
find approximate symmetries for instance
you know on the web graph IBM and Google
and Facebook are approximately symmetric
so you can use this as a proposal
distribution to jump between
approximately symmetric States and all
of these lifted MCMC algorithms they
start to work in this context where you
have evidence and where you have
asymmetry so that problems actually been
kind of solved with with proposal
distributions instead of exact
symmetries
but I do tell a story about AB Strauss
because I might never get a chance to
tell it again but I was a student here
in Berkeley in the mid 50's he came to
visit
he's a number theorist he wasn't number
theorist in a very close friend a writer
and our notes traveled around the world
and would appeared on people's doorsteps
for extended periods as house guests
that's how he got to write so many joint
papers with people they would work out
something and then the friend would have
to write up the paper eros came one year
and all of a sudden he told him you know
I want to learn to drive an automobile
so very reluctantly Strauss agreed to
give him a lesson two guys on the wheel
when they got in the car and Erdos was
behind it really say now let's see what
happens when you turn the thing this way
now let's see what happens when you turn
the wheel that way so one lesson was
enough many days later in the conference
where Erdos was giving a talk completely
off the top of his head he took overhead
projector slides and he would say now
let's see what happens when you take
this series experimental way